[Music]
qualifying as a princess seems pretty
straightforward it turns out who makes
the cut is pretty complicated for one
Disney brand let's find out the only
real requirement to be at Disney
Princess if this is your first time
visiting the things don't forget to
smash that subscribe button and hit that
notification bell prentices are the
bread and butter of Disney the company
released its first feature film in 1937
that film was now the infamous Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs Snow White
won hearts and launched Disney to the
top of the entertainment industry the
film put feature-length animation on the
map and created the phenomenon of the
Disney Princess
after Snow White it would be another 13
years before the next Princess film
Cinderella was released in 1950 giving
fans a second princess to adore cuz if
you tell a wish it will come true nine
years later Sleeping Beauty would
introduce the character Aurora decades
passed before the next Princess film in
1989 the golden age of the princess film
began The Little Mermaid was released to
wild success and became an instant
classic this film began that many refer
to as the Disney Renaissance this period
would be the release of many landmark
titles and introduced the world to four
new characters who would become official
Disney Princesses it might be obvious
who the official Disney Princesses are
if you thought all characters who were
the female children of royalty could
claim the honor you'd be wrong
the term Disney Princess applies to
characters included in the separate
official franchise the brand was created
in 2001 Disney consumer products
employee Andy Mooney saw a market with
unmet needs and II noticed that little
girls were attending a Disney on Ice
Show in princess costumes they weren't
Disney branded or even based on Disney
characters it is evident that many
Disney brands associated the company
with fairytale royalty it seemed there
were thousands of princes fans out there
who would happily buy Cinderella's ball
gown or Ariel's dinglehopper within two
years of its launch the Disney Princess
brand brought in over three billion in
sells the brand offers products from
children's toys and costumes to high-end
cosmetics and Couture the brands appeals
to everyone equally that's a lot of
princess glam with that kind of selling
power it's easy to see why Disney is so
picky about who received a royal
coronation not every royal character
gets to be part of this wildly popular
franchise the original lineup was Snow
White Cinderella Aurora Ariel Belle
Jasmine Pocahontas Mulan and Tinkerbell
in 2005 the lineup changed Disney
noticed the popularity of their fairy
characters and stories and decided to
launch the official Disney fairy brand
Tinkerbell left her throne as an
official Disney Princess and became the
face of the fairy franchise in 2010
Tiana from The Princess and the Frog
enjoyed an extravagant coronation in
2011 Rapunzel was added as well two
years later the first Pixar character
was added to the list with Meredith fans
have speculated for years just what gets
a character on the list the answer may
surprise you
royal heritage isn't a requirement
neither Pocahontas Mulan or Tinkerbell
have any titles there are several
daughters of kings and queens who
haven't made the list either official
princesses don't even have to be the
star of their film Jasmine wasn't the
main protagonists in Aladdin after all
fans have wondered of being human with
requirements but Ariel was once a
mermaid and the original lineup included
a fairy any character introduced in a
sequel is automatically out of the
running as well many may have thought
Disney revealed the big secret with a
line in one of their movies in Moana
Maui refers to Moana as princess
she proudly corrects the demigod that
she's in fact the daughter of a chief
now even says that many believe to be
the Disney princess secret sauce if you
wear a dress and you have an animal
sidekick your princess nice try Maui but
you're way off we'd like to point out
that Moana is wearing a crop top and a
skirt fashion aside not every princess
has an animal sidekick Snow White was a
friend to all animals but none were
particularly significant
Tinkerbell spent all of her time with
humans dad and dad
can't be the criteria what it boils down
to is the princesses original film
earned a precise amount of money if it's
all about cash you may be wondering why
Anna and Elsa aren't on the list
You Belong down in arendelle so do you
frozen became the fifth highest-grossing
movie ever pulling in over a billion
dollars that kind of profit should put
the royal siblings front and center
frozen was so popular Disney made the
characters their own franchise much like
Tinkerbell Elsa and Anna can't be part
of the two franchises at the same time
so what is it that gets a character into
this exclusive club the hunchback of
notre dom was an oscar-nominated hit but
as marauder isn't on the list fans have
asked why kitta from atlantis didn't
make the cut either she's just as strong
as Milan or Merida the key to being a
Disney Princess is to have a box-office
hit film with a huge fan base and as we
saw with frozen a film can do too well
for its characters to make the cut many
assumed Moana would soon join the ranks
she's beloved and even Maui himself
called her Princess it seems Moana may
have fallen into the same category as
her frozen sisters she's so popular that
she gets to be her own brand being too
popular maybe the worst reason to miss
out on a title for the lucky few that
hold the distinction there's quite a lot
of pomp and ceremony
Tiana's crowning in 2010 at the new york
palace in manhattan was a lavish event
there she was warmly welcomed by the
current reigning princesses as well as
fans and the press
Rapunzel enjoyed a decadent ceremony at
Kensington Palace in London her big day
included a royal parade of princesses
and carriages the fun doesn't end there
there are ceremonies at both Disney
World and Disneyland theme parks to
celebrate each new addition this short
list of women from diverse backgrounds
is here to prove one thing being a
princess isn't about what family you
were born into or who you marry a
princess is made through success we hope
you enjoyed finding out what it takes to
be an official Disney Princess we'll see
you next time
[Music]